from singers to dancers and even dog
trainers America's Got Talent chooses
their final seven competitors during the
final week of judge cuts and one of them
gets the golden buzzer the last round of
cuts went down on Tuesdays America's Got
Talent
with only seven spots remaining for the
live show portion of the competition
Grammy award-winning singer and Heidi
Klum's ex-husband seal as guest judge
[Music]
[Applause]
singer Johnny Manuel performed an insane
version of lately by Stevie Wonder
[Applause]
[Music]
it's just flawless I wouldn't change a
thing you just have such a gift I mean
you're just born with this steel loved
him so much so this happened it is
undeniable you hit notes that I could
only dream of
johnny isn't the only one moving on to
next week's live round of competition
the greater works Gospel Choir
solidified their spots by delivering a
moving rendition of Marvin Gaye's ain't
no mountain high enough
[Applause]
the adorable dancing duo are Dion and
Paige also made it through we've already
started planning already as well as a
cappella singing group in the stairwell
the Pompeo family of incredible dog
trainers also landed a spot and of
course 12 year old dancer Marek Hannah
did not disappoint with his performance
as a robot making it into next week's
live shows finally contestant catchy
brought everyone in the audience to
tears with a beautiful cover of John
Hyatts have a little faith in me
[Music]
[Music]
your friend of my strength through
vulnerability now that's a mantra that I
try and live by every day I think there
was no greater example of that and what
you showed we transcend the things that
you have obviously transcended see
that's a true sign of real inner
strength thank you from the bottom of my
heart
[Applause]